how's it going friends my name is and
welcome to disgusting it's been forever
I don't have any excuses but let me do
this
so Krauss is hosting a trials adrenaline
contest you bros have may have seen the
video ma of childs know okay they're
challenging people to do things that are
easy to do but hard to master so I asked
you bros to challenge me on things that
you think are easy to do but hard to
master and here's what you came up with
easy to skate hard to light a trick easy
hard
easy but I own high heels but hard to
walk easy for Jesus knees hardest knees
without making weird faces easy
I chew hard Pro Mode keeping your eyes
open
haha he's gonna play guitar hard to play
without using your hands
that's probably too easy you shouldn't
be pretty difficult to be fabulous a lot
of yummy baby it's not good he's gonna
be a man hard to be a man and get
pregnant right easy hard skip my mana
hey easy climb a tree hard to go down
easy
Lord Oh easier Dame's but hearted
breakdance easy
he's a rapper Tupac ha easy for
it was that guy if you want to do your
own easy to do a hard to master that
I'll leave a link in the description and
you can submit to the trials of doodling
contest I had a lot of fun making it I
would love to check out what you girls
make away as well if you enjoyed
watching please he's cheap [ __ ] you know
I hate you say awesome
I hope you like and get what are you
doing alright there's breakfast for us
stay awesome
you
Oh